HE IS DOING A BETTER JOB OF
THAT.
LOOKS LIKE THE BASKET DOES NOT
COUNT.
PORTER ATTACKING ON THE
OFFENSIVE END, GETTING INTO THE
PAINT AGAINST HARDEN.
>> Stan: YOU HAVE TO ATTACK NOW.
THE NETS ARE LITERALLY SWITCHING
EVERY SCREEN ON AND OFF OF THE
BALL SO YOU ARE ONE-ON-ONE ALL
OF THE TIME.
YOU ARE NEVER GETTING TWO
DEFENDERS ON THE BALL.
>> Brian: PORTER CANNOT KNOCK IT
DOWN.
JOHNSON DEFENDING THERE.
BEMBRY GIVES IT UP.
PLAYMAKER, HARDEN.
THE NETS BY FIVE.
THERE IS KUMINGA.
NOW CURRY WITH THE SWITCH ON TO
HARDEN.
JAMES HARDEN GOES TO WORK.
POUNDING IT.
HARDEN.
CURRY PICKS HIM.
CURRY LAYS OUT AND TOUCHES THE
SIDELINE WITH HIS SHOULDER.
>> Stan: THIS IS GREAT DEFENSE
BY CURRY, WHO IS AN UNDERRATED
DEFENDER.
HE HAS GOTTEN A LOT BETTER AND
JAMES HARDEN DRIBBLING THE AIR
OUT OF THE BALL RIGHT THERE.
THAT IS NOT THE OFFENSE THAT
STEVE NASH WANTS.
>> Grant: THE HELP DEFENSE.
ALL OF THE GUYS HELPING CURRY